alexis me poulin bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
le projet de loi prolongeant de six mois
la possibilité de restreindre
rassemblements et des placements a donc
été examinée aujourd'hui alors cela
permet de prendre vite des décisions
adaptées pour combattre l'épidémie selon
gabriel attal que l'on vient d'entendre
vous le rejoignez écoutez vous savez je
crois que c'est une improvisation géant
est en train de se passer
jean castex était le monsieur
déconfinement avant de devenir premier
ministre et on a l'impression que malgré
les discours rassurants qui avaient été
ceux d'avant la rentrée cette rentrée se
passe dans l'incertitude la plus
complète avec les signaux d alerte des
médecins qui voient à nouveau les
chiffres augmenter et les lits de
réanimation de nouveau se remplir comme
si la première vague finalement n'avait
pas été là où n'avait donné aucune leçon
donc c'est incompréhensible de
comprendre
finalement qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent
des français alors on a compris il faut
mettre le masque partout tout le temps
il faut se laver les mains ça jean
castex l'avait dit et éviter bien
entendu les rassemblements de personnes
trop nombreuses mais au-delà de ça
quelle est la politique sanitaire mis en
place pour les tests on entend beaucoup
de témoignages de gens qui ont attendu
plus de sept jours pour avoir des tests
de manque aussi de produits pour faire
ces tests
tout est à l'envi oui justement lexique
où la hausse des cas vous en parlais à
l'instant deuxième vague
cette situation qu'est ce qu'elle dit
sur la gestion de la crise en france
c'est la faute à pas de chance ou pas
non c'est la faute à l'impréparation
total de des autorités publiques alors
il ya maintenant les préfets qui
s'organise avec les maires avec les
différentes régions pour éviter ce grand
rond confinement nationale qui a été
fait lors de la première vague c'était
la solution d'urgence était la dernière
des solutions
ce confinement qui a coûté cher à
l'économie française et dont on va en
payer le prix
et maintenant on a l'impression qu'il
faut tout faire pour éviter à nouveau à
confinement mais qu'on n'a pas
pris l'ampleur en fait des mesures qu'il
aurait fallu mettre en place regardez
nos voisins en italie on a limité le
nombre d'élèves par classe on a préparé
une rentrée pour que justement les
écoles ne deviennent pas des foyers de
contamination en france c'est plus de
2000 classe maintenant qu'ils sont
fermées des cas qui sont testés dans
beaucoup d'écoles
on a l'impression que tout ça n'aurait
pas dû arriver ou que derrière jean
michel blanquer disait qu'il était prêt
on a vu aussi ses images d'étudiants qui
retournent dans les universités bondé
rien n'est fait non plus là encore pour
éviter ces cas contacts et vous avez le
gouvernement qui dit éviter les
rassemblements familiaux mais ça n'a
aucun sens et y compris dans les
transports enfin je veux dire
aujourd'hui le virus circule on a les
gestes barrières on a le masque mais on
n'a pas l'impression que derrière les
autorités sanitaires ont pris l'ampleur
de leur grotte de la réorganisation
qu'il fallait mettre en place depuis la
première vague
alors concernant la communication de
l'exécutif un point hebdomadaire dès
demain du ministre de la santé sera mis
en place
on a encore des spots comme ceux de la
sécurité routière c'est nécessaire ou
alors c'est anxiogène pour la population
ce qui est nécessaire aujourd'hui c'est
des messages clairs des messages que les
gens comprennent et qu'on arrête enfin
avec les injonctions contradictoires
qu'on explique aux gens oui maintenant
les masques c'est nécessaire mais télé
ça sert à rien de dire anti mètres mais
aussi mais télé avec mon sens c'est à
dire ça ne sert à rien de continuer avec
la politique de la répression et de la
demande
les gens en ont ras-le-bol donc il faut
aujourd'hui avoir un message simple
clair et puis avoir derrière les lignes
de de la gestion de cette épidémie qui
sont mises en place
les lits qui ont été faits en urgence en
réanimation lors de la première vague
n'ont pas été pérennisée aujourd'hui les
ars continue de fermer des lits et les
services de réanimation ne sont pas
mieux dotés que la dernière fois
il n'y a pas eu de réflexion sur la
médecine de ville il n'y a pas eu de
réflexion sur la façon de faire les
tests qu'elle teste vatan choisir on a
l'impression que le gouvernement attend
simplement de voir comment l'épidémie va
progresser et qu'un jour il y aura un
vaccin et que tout ira bien
c'est pas le cas et les autres les
entreprises également attendent
attendent aussi des consignes claires
que faire quand on est parent que son
enfant a été contaminé
l'école qu'il ne peut plus aller à
l'école comment on le garde comment on
fait est ce que aujourd'hui les open
space c'est vivable de vivre huit heures
par jour avec un masque ça me paraît
extrêmement compliqué pour est pour
beaucoup ça l'est donc rien n'a été
pensé en amont
il serait temps que ce soit le cas et
qu'on arrête au gouvernement de faire
que de la communication
alors les auditions ont repris l au
sénat est ce que cette commission dans
lequel elle a toute son utilité
aujourd'hui oui elle est extrêmement
importante pour poser les
responsabilités parce qu'on voit bien
que depuis le début de cette crise
l'idée est de diluer la responsabilité
et aujourd'hui le gouvernement va se
défausser à la fois sur le conseil
scientifique et puis ensuite sur les
préfets les maires et et les régions
pour éviter de dire que les mauvaises
décisions ont été prises en amont mais
il faudra répondre aux questions
pourquoi la doctrine sur le co vide 19
lakovic 19 à enlever le masque pour les
métiers de contact
alors que c'était une recommandation de
la doctrine pour le h1n1
on a gommé les masques de toute la
doctrine pourquoi on a menti en français
en disant que le masque était inutile
soit disant qu'à l'époque on ne savait
pas arrêté les médecins peu été en
première ligne demandait des masques
demander des équipements ils ne les
avaient pas il va savoir
il va falloir comprendre pourquoi
emmanuel macron aller au théâtre est
demandé à tous les français d'aller au
théâtre moins de quinze jours avant
d'organiser le grand confinement quelle
a été la chaîne de responsabilités qui a
fait que les décisions ont été mauvaises
de a à z
donc oui cette commission denquête elle
est extrêmement importante pour qu'enfin
on sache qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé
et qu'est-ce qu'il se passe encore
aujourd'hui dans notre pays peut-être un
mot sur conclure pour conclure sur le co
vide reconnu comme maladie
professionnelle
mais il faut avoir un contracté une
forme sévère est ce que c'est une
définition juste selon vous c'est une
définition a minima parce que vous avez
la forme longue du coc vide qu'il va
falloir prouver et puis vous avez le
problème des gens qui l'ont contractée
dans la sphère professionnelle et pour
le prouver il ne faut pas avoir eu de
temps d'arrêt ou bien être avoir un
temps de travail particulier donc c'est
encore une fois pour limiter le nombre
de personnes qui rentreraient dans la
case maladies professionnelles alors que
la réalité c'est que beaucoup de
soignants ont été mis
danger par le manque de moyens est
finalement l'économie de moyens
organisée par le gouvernement et les
autorités sanitaires
si beaucoup alexis poulain je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialistes